how am i doing
well
uh within the last roughly 24 hours
joe biden's approval rating dropped to
33 percent
kamala harris is refusing to say if she
and joe will even run for re-election
kirsten cinema and joe manchin killed
chuck schumer's crusade to abolish the
filibuster meaning that the federal
election takeover and the build back
broke budget are deader than disco to
say nothing of the even more radical
policy proposals such as i don't know
court packing and speaking of the court
the united states supreme court just
handed us
the american people and specifically the
daily wire
and historic
and somewhat unexpected judicial victory
by smacking down joe biden's illegal
vaccine mandate and allowing americans
to decide for themselves whether or not
they want to inject themselves with
fouchy juice
so i'd say i'm feeling pretty
pretty good
i'm michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from leonard
tomasios who says
listening to what the dems want to do
with voting reminds me of that scene
from the five gangs of new york where
they ask a guy how many times he voted
three times and then they tell him to
shave and vote again
yes it would remind you of that because
that was also the democrats back then
and they've been doing this for the
entire history of their uncommonly
corrupt party
political parties political operations
involve some degree of corruption that
has always been the case in democratic
politics lowercase d but the democrat
party capital d has been particularly
corrupt on this front they did it way
back in tammany hall and gangs in new
york they did it in chicago in the
mid-20th century they're doing it now
but unfortunately their efforts to seize
all that power and upend more of our
election system their efforts are deader
than disco because joe biden is having
the worst week possibly
of his political career
you know it just it makes you think
that even as things are falling apart in
this country there are a few tangible
valuable things we can hold on to
for instance birch gold
it's really important to diversify your
investments all the time but especially
when the economy is a little kooky right
now inflation is at 40 year highs
4-0 it's here to stay
do you know why it's here to stay
because the government's dirty little
secret is they want it
think about this right now inflation
rates are higher than the interest on
treasury bonds so with every day that
passes the government owes less on its
mountain of debt
imagine for instance if your mortgage
had a negative interest rate would you
be in a hurry to pay it off would you
make extra payments every month
and no i don't think so so your pain is
the government's gain protect your
savings now hedge against inflation with
gold from birch gold because the
government is sabotaging the value of
the u.s dollar birch gold will help you
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by real gold that is peace of
mind that's why i am a huge huge fan of
birch gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
nulls kwles to 989898
to get a free info kit on holding gold
in a tax sheltered account then call
birch and protect your hard earned
savings text null scanner wles to
9898.98 to get your free info kit now go
check out birch gold
today
all right madam vice president
everything's falling apart the
president's approval rating is terrible
yours is somehow even worse all of your
legislative priorities dead your
administrative priorities dead because
of the supreme court
the american people rejecting what you
want
across the entire board
how are you going to change course
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change strategies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
franklin roosevelt famously said
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
ronald reagan famously said
mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
and kamala harris famously said
it's the time now to do what we've been
doing every day in the time
and the time to agree that we are doing
that we've got things to do together and
the time
powerful it's really power doesn't it
sends a shiver up your spine shiver up
your spine to think that this woman
could become the vice president of the
united states she is obviously a good
politician
she is by definition she's a good
politician she's the vice president
i called this by the way you know i hate
to say i told you so i called this
during the 2020 democrat primaries i
said watch kamala harris people laughed
at me they said ha ha camalera she's
terrible i said watch kamala harris
then she's one of the first people out
they laugh at me they say ha ha michael
you idiot the kamalaris isn't going
anywhere
kamala harris is a heartbeat away from
the presidency and the current president
doesn't have a very strong heart
so she's clearly a good politician she's
worked her way up she's not particularly
academically distinguished she's not
particularly professionally
distinguished but she worked her way up
in politics
through various mechanisms that we don't
need to get into here
she became a united states senator and
she became the vice president at a
relatively young age that's impressive
but she's a terrible
communicator she is
she is less coherent than joe biden
and joe biden
has problems in between his ears right
now okay and somehow she's worse
this is the only thing politically joe
biden has going for him is that his vice
president is somehow less popular than
he is
even though he's extremely unpopular his
vice president is somehow less coherent
than he is even though he's obviously in
the throes of senility
that is something because
potentially i could stave off an
impeachment
if joe biden even lasts if he even makes
it that far
really bad news
for the democratic ticket in 2024 so bad
that kamala harris
refuses to say that that she and joe
will even be running during the next
presidential cycle
are we going to uh to see the same
democratic ticket in 2024
i'm sorry we are thinking about today i
mean honestly that i i know why you're
asking the question because this is the
part of the punditry and the the gossip
around places like washington d.c let me
just tell you something we're focused on
the things in front of us
uh
uh we're just uh uh lady this is not a
hard question this is not an unexpected
question how do you not have an answer
for this question this is basic stuff
for a vice president especially in a
troubled administration
we're we're
just thinking about today no we're
obviously not just thinking about today
that's why the interviewer asked the
question are you going to be on the
ticket
but she can't say
that she or or biden are going to be on
the ticket
why
because the administration is underwater
and because they haven't accomplished
anything this is the best news for
conservatives is they really
have not accomplished much of anything
their entire legislative agenda has been
destroyed
they can't even pass a budget they can't
even pass a budget the buildback better
program is dead and it was killed
obviously the the republicans were
opposed to it but then it was killed
decisively by a couple of democrats
the filibuster killed by
republicans and a couple of democrats
the filibuster
abolition plan
the court packing the federal election
takeover the whole thing so they were
not able even though joe biden had
served in the senate for i think 350
years he wasn't able to use those
relationships to
bring his legislative agenda over on
capitol hill so then he tried to figure
out a workaround his work around was
going to be to use the administrative
state the agencies to force through his
vaccine mandate
that didn't work either because the
court shot it down
so why would
biden and harris run again
what have they done what could they run
on what accomplishment what promise of
an accomplishment could they run on
they've got
nothing they've got nothing
and we have got
the republicans to thank sure but but
joe manchin and kirsten cinema
have just come out there was some debate
will they won't they mansion kind of
killed the budget
but then what about the filibuster
kirsten cinema comes out and says now
the filibuster it's got to stay
i share the concerns of civil rights
advocates and others i've heard from in
recent months about these state laws
i strongly support those efforts to
contest these laws in court and to
invest significant resources into these
states to better organize and stop
efforts to restrict access at the ballot
box and i strongly support and will
continue to vote for legislative
responses to address these state laws
including the freedom to vote act and
the john lewis voting rights advancement
act that the senate is currently
considering and while i continue to
support these bills
i will not support separate actions that
worsen the underlying disease of
division infecting our country the
debate over the senate 60 vote threshold
shines a light on our broader challenges
there's no need for me to restate my
long-standing support for the 60-vote
threshold to pass legislation
there's no need for me to restate its
role protecting our country from wild
reversals and federal policy
this is a really coherent
honest answer from a politician about as
honest and coherent as it gets from a
politician she's not saying that she
doesn't support the power grab
she's not saying she doesn't support
a federal takeover of elections she's
not saying she doesn't support the
democrats legislative
priorities she's saying she doesn't
think that the power grab is worth it
so she's taking away
some of the
the disingenuous emotionally
manipulative talking points language we
need this or the poor oppressed people
will lose their sacred right to vote and
she's she's not doing that she's saying
yeah i support this bill
but but the filibuster is more important
because the filibuster is a great
defense of our constitutional system
because though what we are in power
right now not for very long probably by
the way
though we are in power right now and we
hate the filibuster because it's slowing
down our agenda when we are out of power
if we are ever out of power again
we're gonna really want the filibuster
that's why chuck schumer gave such an
impassioned defense of the filibuster in
2005 which tom cotton read on the floor
of the senate just a couple of days ago
using chuck schumer's words against him
that's why joe biden in 2005 gave an
impassioned defense of how the
filibuster is a great bulwark against
threats to our democracy but but that
was then when he was out of power now
he's in power
and he wants to get rid of it and it's
short-sighted as what kirsten cinema is
saying she's saying guys don't be stupid
we're gonna want this thing
in about
one year when we're out of power and
we're gonna need it to
stop the republicans
or in
three years potentially when we're going
to have a republican president so
let's keep it let's cool it
we are not a mere radical mob rule type
of democracy we're a constitutional
republic
let's be responsible and in so doing
let's kill joe biden's 21 and 2022
agenda
so biden makes a last-ditch effort
to save
any sort of agenda he's got
he can't pass anything through capitol
hill so he uses the administrative
agencies and
the supreme court says no thanks
and this case
it's a very personal case for us because
we were helping to lead it we at the
daily wire sued the biden administration
over their
vaccine mandate through the occupational
safety and health administration
so we got an early win in the fifth
circuit court of appeals
the fifth circuit court of appeals said
okay we're gonna stop the mandate from
going into effect until the legal
process plays out until we determine
whether or not on the merits this rule
is
legal or not
then all of those lawsuits hours and
others were compiled into the sixth
circuit court of appeals the sixth
circuit reversed the fifth circuit and
said no the vaccine mandate is going to
go into effect sorry tough luck the
legal process is going to play out you
might be proven right in the end but
until then everyone's got to take the
jab
which is bs because if we are proven
right in the end but we've already
forced everyone to get the jab then it's
a pyrrhic victory it doesn't mean
anything
not even not even just a periodic
victory it's an utterly meaningless
victory
so the supreme court decides they're
going to take it up they do the oral
arguments
and a lot of us thought it wasn't going
to work
and then it did the majority opinion 63
says
that
the vaccine mandate
should not go into effect until the
legal process plays out but it actually
goes further than that it says
that the
legal process is very very likely
to favor
the people who oppose the vaccine
mandate so it doesn't just say we're
going to pause it until the judges make
their decision it puts its thumb on the
scale and it says the right decision is
to get rid of this rule this rule is
illegal this rule is unconstitutional so
because of the way our legal system is
set up we're going to let this thing
play out but
i dare you
to say that this rule is constitutional
it's not it's bs that was the majority
that was the order of the court
then there was a concurring opinion
by
the conservatives on the court and the
and the opinion by the conservatives and
the dissent from the court's liberals
actually begin in the same way they both
begin and they say the question here is
not about
covid or how deadly covet is the
question here is not really about the
vaccines or the vaccine effectiveness
the question is who decides
who decides it reminds one of antonin
scalia's great descent in the obergefell
case that the case that redefined
marriage where he said
as a political matter i don't really
care that much about
about the definition of marriage that's
when i'm sitting here in the supreme
court in my robe
what marriage means is not the primary
question the primary question is who
rules me who governs who decides
and
according to the majority on the court
the people should decide
so it shouldn't just be some random
administrative agency
that was apparently just a legal work
around because joe biden knew he
couldn't get his mandate passed through
the legislature
it should be the people through their
elected representatives because of court
precedent there's something called the
major questions doctrine which is on
major questions sweeping issues of
public policy
you want to make sure that congress is
speaking with a clear voice and actually
giving to these agencies the powers that
they are presuming to have does anyone
really think that osha
osha the agency that tells you to wear a
hard hat on a construction site
is is now the agency in charge of the
most significant public health questions
in the united states
no nobody really thinks that and
furthermore
even if congress had delegated that
power to this administrative agency
let's say they delegated that power
because they don't want to be
accountable to the voters
congress says yikes i don't any way i
vote on this it's going to be really bad
i might not get reelected so okay i'm
going to give all this power to make all
public health decisions in america to
this administrative agency then i don't
have to deal with it at the town halls
the
conservatives point out there's another
doctrine at play the non-delegation
doctrine that there are some
responsibilities that congress cannot
delegate away to the agencies even if it
wants to
even if
they try and they put it clearly in law
sometimes that is unconstitutional
and that's what the conservatives on the
court are saying now the liberals on the
court came at this question of who
decides
from a different vantage they came at it
and they said okay who's going to decide
these public health questions
the expert geniuses
who are public health gurus who have
been given some modicum of authority
from congress
or the supreme court
us
a bunch of robed lawyers who have no
expertise on this
who do you want making health care
decisions for you the physicians who
have been appointed to bureaucratic
roles in the government
or us lawyers
but
are those the only two options i i
thought there were more options
what about oh i don't know
the people's representatives shouldn't
they have some say in this
well that was the argument of the
conservatives and by the way they
observed that
when the congress has weighed in on joe
biden's mandate
it weighed in to voice its disapproval
the senate passed a resolution that said
it disapproves of the osha mandate
so as as much as we can tell what the
voice of the people is on this
in our constitutional system where the
people speak through their elected
representatives the people oppose this
and the elected legislators oppose this
but but for the libs they don't care
they don't really care what the people
think they're extremely distrustful of
american democracy they want decisions
to either be made by
a handful of unaccountable people in the
government bureaucracy or a handful of
unaccountable people on the supreme
court and what the conservatives said is
no there's actually more to our
government darling so maybe you've been
reading a little too much woodrow wilson
you've been reading a little too much
franklin roosevelt and progressive
literature actually the people still
have a say actually local communities
state governments
local governments the family for that
matter has a say
what i loved so much about the
conservative opinion
is that it wasn't some radical
libertarian opinion
it didn't say my body my choice it
didn't say the government has no right
to force you to take some kind of
inoculation because that wouldn't be
true
there is long-standing precedent in the
united states that in certain public
health emergencies certain governmental
authorities can order you to take a
vaccine
actually going back to even before the
constitution going back to george
washington in the continental army he
forced his soldiers to take a smallpox
inoculation a very dangerous one that
killed a lot of them so there is
long-standing precedent legally in
american culture going all the way back
to the american revolution
i know it's fashionable now for
many conservatives this is probably the
consensus view to say look i'm
pro-vaccine but anti-mandate
i'm kind of the opposite
i think in this case where you have a
virus that is not particularly dangerous
to the vast vast vast majority of people
and you can deal separately with the
people who are at risk but for the vast
majority of people it's just not that
dangerous
and you've got a vaccine that is
experimental that is quite new it's a
new vaccine technology and it has failed
to do
some of the things that joe biden and dr
fauci and rochelle wallenski promised us
it would do
so
the predictions of of how the vaccine
were going to work did not really come
to fruition
in that case i don't think that young
healthy people have any reason to go get
it however i do think that at least the
local government has the right to
mandate it because we do have political
rights as a community and obviously
during times of epidemic
the state has certain emergency and
police powers
so that the conservatives on the court
understood this they say look we're not
saying that state and local governments
don't have the right to mandate these
sorts of things they do
but the federal government
has less power to mandate these things
and some random workplace health agency
has way less power to mandate these
things
and frankly the the way they've issued
this rule
is insincere and preposterous
because yes they're tasked with passing
workplace safety regulations
but
just because people might have kovid if
they go to work
doesn't mean that now the workplace
safety agency can can force you to take
a shot that's a huge overstep of their
authority
furthermore it the liberals kept
focusing in the in their descent
on how dangerous kovid was to american
workers but is that really the case
what's the median age of a covid death
north of 80.
so the median age of a covid death
is
af well after the age of retirement
people who are not really working
anymore
moreover the risk of hospitalization or
death from covid skews heavily toward
the the side of the age spectrum after
retirement age
so what percentage
of american workers people of working
age
are actually at grave risk of
hospitalization or death from kovid
i suspect
the the number for all americans
generally is extremely small but i
suspect the number of workers is much
much much much smaller
so the liberals case i think it fails
on
the the argument they were trying to
make from covid and from the vaccine
specifically
they barely even made a legal case and
the conservatives argument
was about as strong as it could be it
wasn't a total win because
the supreme court forced health care
workers for instance to get the vaccines
which i think everyone expected to
happen
but we do need to take the wins where we
can get them when we can get them this
is the case that at least we here in
this building have been fighting this is
the case that you have been fighting by
subscribing by signing up by signing our
petition the do not comply petition
this is the case where we focused all of
our energy
and we won
and we won and it's a good day for
american rights and freedom and our way
of life
a very bad day for joe biden
so now that biden's got all this
terrible news
joe biden is making a special appeal
to
the
establishment media to the big tech
companies that run the social media he's
saying look
i'm losing on capitol hill
i'm losing in the agencies please
please
shut down dissent
unfortunately while our military is
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines
and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america has ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other
ann coulter pointed out yesterday she
said
what is it called when the government
controls all of the corporations and
uses the ostensibly private corporations
to carry out the will of the state is
that what's that
something about a bundle of sticks i
does that starts with an f ends with an
ashism is i forget what do they call
that i forget
this is proof positive
of
two contentions that i've made on this
show for a long time that a lot of
conservatives have gotten
aware of in in recent years one is that
liberals are the ruling class
they are the established power they
present themselves as the opposition
we're gonna speak truth to power we're
gonna fight the patriarchy we're gonna
fight the white supremacy we're gonna
fight the conservative establishment but
the conservatives don't have any
institution in the country we don't
control a single one
talk radio is about as close as it gets
and and even that is regulated by the
administrative agencies which we don't
have
the liberals are the establishment
liberals run the government liberals run
the bureaucracy liberals run the
corporations liberals run the
universities liberals run the media
liberals run big tech liberals run
everything
second contention that joe biden just
proved is that the journalists
by and large are fake news
because
the journalists
he joe biden is speaking to these
journalists like good friends
it's different than when trump says
you're fake news i hate you you're scum
he would go to his rallies he'd say look
at those people back there look at those
press they're the scum of the earth
they're slime they're fake news
that was a very adversarial relationship
and the media started it what joe
biden's doing here is he's talking like
a friend he's saying hey guys come on
hey big tech ceos
hey
heads of the corporate press
you got it cool at letting these
conservatives on it's too much these
conservatives are really they're really
a thorn in my side
so come on guys
cool it with that i know i know that
you're already
extremely unfair to conservatives on
facebook and youtube and twitter i know
that you're extremely unfair to
conservatives in the corporate press you
got to be even more unfair
it's just because they're still getting
their message out and their message is
still resonating with the american
people and it's really hurting my
approval ratings so you got to stop it
you got to stop it and even still even
with
the entire power structure in this
country against us
even then
we
sometimes get
victories
increasingly so i don't want to toot our
own horn here at the daily wire we've
had a lot of victories recently okay
many people
thought that the daily wire played a
role in the virginia governor's race
going against the democrat going for
terry mcauliffe because of some
investigative journalism we did not
because of some political operation but
because we went in we found a story that
the
corrupt corporate press was suppressing
namely that in loudoun county a
gender confused boy raped a girl in the
girl's bathroom and the school covered
it up and the school transferred him
the rapist to another school and you
know what happened take a guess he did
it again and they covered it up and they
smeared the parents of the victim they
smeared the dad in particular
and the
doj
and the established powers in washington
dc they called these parents terrorists
and we dug into that story pulled on
that needle a little bit pulled on that
thread rather
and it turned out
that there was rank hideous corruption
well that rapist has now been sentenced
and put on the sex offender registry for
life
14 years old by the way
14 year old boy raped a 9th grader
what put it in his mind to do that
maybe he was already a little messed up
but what happened was he looking at the
increasingly violent pornography that
pervades the culture was he i don't know
one should look into these questions but
he committed his crime
while he was wearing a skirt
well he was allowed to go into the girls
bathroom because to be politically
correct now all of the liberal schools
are letting boys into the girls room and
conservatives said this is a risk this
is a threat girls should not have to
deal with this and the the liberals said
that we were intolerant bigoted
transphobes that women face no threats
from this and then what happens a boy
rapes a girl in the girls bathroom
the judge reading out the sentence
said
that
sh i think it was a she i don't remember
if it was a he or she i guess that's the
question these days we all ask ourselves
but the judge had had not
forced kids to be put on the sex
offender registry for life
but this judge was so shocked at the
details of this kid's crimes
says over the years this court has read
many psychosexual reports and when i
read yours frankly it scared me it
scared me for you it scared me for
society all of this
all of this
to defend
transgender bathrooms
all of this
a superintendent covering up a rape
transferring a kid imperiling other
girls
stonewalling the parents going after the
parents stonewalling the press all of
this to defend
insane policies
that are intended to indulge
delusion it's all about transgenderism
well if a few girls get raped in their
bathroom that's just the price we have
to pay for progress
can't make an omelette without cracking
a few eggs a few fourteen-year-old girl
eggs
that's what they're saying
the
important progressive social crusade
to
let boys pretend to be girls
is worth a few girls getting raped
evil stuff worth pushing back on and
that's the sort of thing
that we did
that's the sort of thing speaking of
punishment before we get into the
mailbag iran is threatening to
assassinate
donald trump and mike pompeo
take a look at this this video take a
listen
so this is
being released by the supreme leader of
iran
showing this military operation very
high tech all these iranian operatives
working on their computers they've got
drones they've got little
little machines outside of mar-a-lago
trump and pompeo are playing golf there
going all around they're gonna they're
gonna target them they put they put the
light they put the focus on trump and
pompeo
eventually what happens you get the
point eventually what happens is they
assassinate them
this
video that iran released
shows two things
shows one that they probably can't
assassinate trump and they're not going
to do it because if they were going to
assassinate trump they'd just
assassinate him
but they can't do that so they're going
to try to release some
b-level hollywood video showing their
their fantasy about killing trump two it
shows that they consider trump the enemy
and biden the friend biden ostensibly is
the president of the united states
shouldn't they be going after him if
they're going to retaliate for an action
of the united states no they're going
after trump because they consider trump
the enemy and biden the friend because
trump treated iran like a rogue state
and biden is trying to suck up to iran
and biden is trying to reinstate the
iran deal
shows you
the way
that
our american politics is looking right
now shows you the way that our foreign
policy is looking and it shows you
something else iran is impotent at the
moment to kill donald trump iran is
impotent to fulfill its agenda
joe biden is impotent on that front too
big win for us we're so thrilled thank
you to everyone for
for
uh signing our petition for signing the
do not comply petition for the rest of
the day we are using the code winning
for 40 off daily wire membership 4-0
just a thank you to everybody that's
today only we'll be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
my favorite time of the week when i get
to hear from you in the mailbag
first one up from eric hi michael last
year i asked you a relationship question
regarding an issue with my girlfriend
and you encouraged me to marry her in
order to solve a lot of the issues we
had well i brought her to the spot where
we had our first kiss got down on one
knee and now we're engaged hey that's
great we're so happy and thank you for
encouraging me to man up and settle down
with this incredible woman my question
is since you answer so many dating
questions
when will the daily wire release a 10
part series about how to date like a
conservative hosted by you the daily
wire love guru michael knowles p.s we
live in canada and when i first met my
fiance she was a giant trudeau fan and i
converted her to become a freedom loving
conservative that this is all every part
of that is really really great news my
friend congratulations
and in answer to your question when will
the daily wire make a 10-part series on
how to date with the love guru michael
knowles
not soon enough
that's why
i i assume jeremy listens to every
episode of my show jeremy let's go come
on man
we must give the people what they want
from william
michael you take a simplistic view of
the phrase you can't legislate morality
yes you can make laws that require
people to adhere to what you consider a
moral lifestyle but that does not mean
they will be moral in their hearts you
can pass a law that everyone must pray
on their knees in the town square three
times a day when the bell in the church
tower rings if they fail they will be
bullwhipped with a law like that
everyone will show up and get on their
knees and recite the requisite prayer
but that does not mean they'll be
thinking of god instead of the candy bar
they'd rather be eating or the tax forms
they should be filling out or the
chicken they have to buy for dinner
you will not have made a more moral
religious society just one that fears
the whip my friend
you are taking a simplistic view of
ritual and the incarnate nature of
ourselves of our god and of our society
what you are saying it would seem to me
is that it doesn't matter if people do
good things
if they are not feeling
good emotions
if their heart is not in the right place
if they're not feeling the spirit
however you want to put it
what you are taking is a very modern
emotivist view of things and that is not
only
out of keeping with our political
tradition it's actually out of keeping
with the christian tradition it's a very
modern idea that what you do physically
doesn't matter all that matters is what
you're feeling at any given time
so it doesn't matter if you get down on
your knees to pray
you can just pray i don't know why
you're brushing your teeth
but you got but all that matters is that
you really really feel it you know
you don't need to
receive the sacraments the sacraments
which defined the christian faith for
at least what 16 centuries or so
what what you just need to do is just
really feel things intensely and then
but that's that's very personal it's
very emotivist it's very
modern and it it
ignores the fact that we have bodies and
our bodies matter and it actually does
matter
what we do
this this is why a lot of people who are
drawn to the emotivist style of religion
and politics they want to ignore parts
of the bible that talk about how faith
without works is dead they want to talk
about they want to ignore
aspects of the bible such as the
particular judgment they want to ignore
the fact that we will be judged in some
degree on how we behave
we will be judged to send christ talks
about this that you you won't get out
until you pay the very last farthing
which there are
extraordinarily fruitful theological
discussions that can come out of just
that passage but we don't have time for
that right now hopefully we'll get to it
in the future sometime has to do a
little bit with purgatory has to do a
little bit with penance has but anyway
we'll get to that at some later time
what you do with your body really does
matter
why do we have laws against murder we
have laws against murder to stop people
from murdering but michael
just because we have laws that maybe the
people won't murder but they'll still be
murderers in their heart okay but it
would be good if they're not murderers
with their axes and their guns and their
knives
and furthermore
though we deny this today the law is an
instructor
as saint paul writes the civil authority
is
there for you as a gift of god for your
own good
the law can help to shape us why do
parents have rules for their kids
don't eat the cookies after
eight o'clock at night don't go reach
into that cookie jar well okay but
there's still a cookie eater in their
heart there's still gluttons in their
heart no actually the rules over time
will help to shape and educate and bring
up the kids that's why
you hear this expression sometimes with
people who have really bad habits they
say you weren't raised right
you didn't have the right rules the
rules weren't enforced correctly
you weren't raised right but but the law
raises a society as well
and
political thinkers are the statesmen who
built our country understood that
uh they're that yes you can say politics
is downstream of culture i almost don't
even want to use that phrase anymore
because it's been so horribly abused by
people who don't want to actually do
their job in politics and govern but
it could be equally true to say that
culture is downstream of politics right
now
in germany east germany is 10 religious
90 atheist west germany is more than 50
religious why is that
is it because of cultural variations in
bratwurst
i don't think so
i think it's because one country was
dominated by
a generally religious or religious
friendly
polity
and the east part
was dominated by an officially atheist
government and there are cultural
effects personal effects of that policy
as well
do not be an emotivist
life is about more than your feelings
from john hey michael i've noticed that
a lot of our most common political
discussion especially in my personal
life with lots of people who don't read
much the things are we argue are based
off of false premises climate change is
really bad therefore we should do this
the war on drugs didn't work therefore
we should not do this
george floyd was murdered by a racist
cop therefore we should do this is there
any way to really get these false
premises overturned or are we too late
and how do we stop new false promises
from being so widely accepted so we can
have a more intelligent and useful
political debate sincerely came for ben
stayed for and subscribed for and
upgraded for michael oh that's so great
thank you for doing that
yes well the simplest way is to ignore
them in our real lives don't call men
who think that they're women she
don't indulge the george floyd liturgies
where we treat him as though he were
some sort of saint
don't
don't
indulge in the
global warming liturgies where we
treat the earth as though
as she is a goddess and she's about to
die
just don't do it you can laugh at that
you can joke about that and always go
back to the premises when you're having
a sort of debate but then furthermore
this shows the need to exercise
political power
you need to exercise political power
especially in education because if kids
are indoctrinated into these false
premises then they're going to come to
logical conclusions on blm on global
warming on the war on drugs or whatever
from their faulty premises and they're
going to be really deeply ingrained when
our brains are really mushy when we're
kids so you've got to go in there you've
got to wield government power
and political power to shape curricula
and you've got to do that down the line
as well right now
if i
oppose
transgenderism for instance let's look
at canada because canada's further down
the line already in canada if i call a
man
who thinks he's a woman he
i may be in violation of the law
i may in parts of europe i may be in
violation of some sort of hate crime
that's really bad so the law is already
putting its finger on the scales of
delusion and false premises we need to
wield the law on the side of truth and
what's good and what's right and what's
beautiful from alex
michael my question for you is
i want to be eligible to join the state
troopers academy in a couple of years
it's always been my dream to be a state
trooper growing up in a christian
conservative home my family and friends
have mixed feelings about it as some of
them highly encourage me and others say
they don't believe christians belong in
the police force
your thoughts on this issue would be
really appreciated thanks love the show
yeah reread saint paul who says as i
just quoted that the civil authority is
there for your own good instituted by
god and that the civil authority does
not wield the sword in vain there's
there's nothing unchristian
about
good government and and good laws and
ensuring just justice is pretty good
justice is a virtue my friend so
i think your family is a little confused
on that
if the issue is that your family thinks
that christians should never engage in
violence then i would have them well i
would have them read lots of literature
but something really easy to read would
be
would be c.s lewis's essay on why he's
not a pacifist that's where i'd begin
and if you want to join the troopers
good job please don't pull me over if
you see me speeding
but great stuff it's a good career from
victor dear michael a teacher asked for
my preferred pronouns in a questionnaire
should i just leave it blank no you
should find a new teacher
i mean it i mean it
because your teacher asking for
preferred pronouns means your teacher is
one of three things
an idiot who doesn't know what sex is
a radical ideologue
who
is taken with delusional theories
or a coward maybe a normal person who's
just going along to get along because
the politically correct administrators
are forcing them to
either way
or any of those three ways or any
combination thereof
probably not going to be a great teacher
from maya
i was disappointed with you today
regarding your opinion of maya angelou's
poetry you're entitled to your opinion
but i would encourage you to actually
read her body of work i have read maya
angelou's
poetry her poetry was written by a wise
woman whose life experiences can be a
blessing to people no matter their color
do not dwell on the fact that she is a
woman or a woman of color read the words
hold on i i don't dislike maya angelou's
work because she's a woman or because
she's black i dislike her work because
it's bad poetry
and i oppose her being put on a coin on
the new quarter because she's a bad poet
and i don't think a particularly
accomplished person
but also because she is being promoted
as a token explicitly by the people who
are promoting her they're saying this is
so great because she's black or this is
so great because she's a woman and i
think it's wrong to engage in that kind
of tokenism i think it's very
disrespectful to our country to
everybody to people of all races and to
people of all sexes or both sexes i
guess i should say but her poetry is not
great there are female writers that i
like very much there are black writers
that i like very much
woman writers i think are very talented
black writers i think are very talented
maya angelou is not one of them i'm
sorry she's not a good poet there's no
disputing taste some people say de gusti
bus nunes desputandum but in this case i
think there is disputandum
and i just don't think she's very very
good
and i would encourage you my i say this
with great charity and great love for
you
i think there's there are better poets
you should read maybe you like my i
don't i don't begrudge you your maya
angelou but i think there are better
poets that you could read as well of all
races of all sexes and so on from
patrick hey michael i've heard you
reference ancient heresies frequently
just wondering if you think pope
francis's comments that getting
vaccinated is a moral obligation are
heretical or merely idiotic if they are
heretical have we seen this heresy
before
p.s 53 pages of footnotes and speechless
impressive pps i'm sorry i'm not named
nick that's very kind thanks for reading
speechless
gotta be very particular here about what
pope francis said
pope francis is a jesuit
jesuits can be jesuitical sometimes they
can use very sly
reasoning and argumentation to make it
seem like they're saying one thing but
actually it's they're saying another
thing and sometimes pope francis is
misquoted
i do not believe pope francis said that
getting vaccinated is a moral obligation
he said that a getting vaccinated is a
healthy care and a healthy care is a
moral obligation
so
sure vaccinations are a type of health
care but not all health care
interventions are morally obligated and
so there's it's a clever kind of turn of
phrase but it's it's the way that he can
avoid saying that receiving this vaccine
is morally obligatory because it's not
not only is it not morally obligatory it
might not be morally permissible the
bishops have come out and said you you
can get these vaccines
they're giving you a special permission
but the reason they even have to give
you a permission is because the vaccines
were all developed and in some cases
produced with stem cells from aborted
babies so it involves the remote
cooperation with evil and the bishops
are saying in this case we are giving
you the permission to do that
but no one can require you can say it's
obligatory to to cooperate with evil
this
is
one of the many issues with francis's
papacy which has been somewhat confusing
there have been questions raised
questions about potential heresy that he
has spouted called dubia doubts
he hasn't really answered those so i
hope he answers those and clears up
clears up the issue last question from
matthew dear mr knowles my question does
not relate to the formal sub the normal
subjects of the mailbag namely
relationships and religion it relates to
an interview you had with michael anton
a few days ago i agree with anton that
while we have many parallels with rome
particularly late republican rome there
are many that are unprecedented uh
trends in our current situation however
let's say we're on the rome timeline in
this case do you see an augustus caesar
augustus figure rising to power in the
future
additionally what should be our verdict
on augustus's regime was he a visionary
leader who assured rome's place in
history or a tyrant who betrayed rome's
core republican values thanks love the
show caesar augustus came to power
not not by or julius caesar for that
matter did not come to power
because they took this wonderful idyllic
republic in rome and then took it over
like tyrants republican rome was
decadent and debaugh late republican
room was decadent and debauched and
messed up and screwy and they took power
because the resume regime was changing
the regime had decayed this is what we
call anacyclosis the cycle of regimes
there are good forms of government
democracy aristocracy monarchy there are
bad forms of that same government mob
rule oligarchy and tyranny and the
regimes decay and they change and they
move around so what do i think of caesar
augustus i think he was one of the
greatest leaders in the history of the
world called the prince of peace who
reigned actually while the prince of
peace was right
caesar augustus led to the the
roman peace the pax romana
christ the actual prince of peace was
born in that that sort of he lived in
that sort of rome that era of rome uh
caesar augustus was called the son of
the divine
and christ is the son of god there are
interesting historical parallels that
are going on here who what will happen
here in america our regime will decay at
some point that's just what happens who
will be our caesar
that remains to be seen i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin